[Music]
hi mind if I touch your wiener what my
dog
[Music]
court order for asset seizures so
they're taking my car you and radio
silent on me is that what this is about
just last night and I thought I missed
that is that true buongiorno
that's my cousin Gary I swear to God
he's my cousin he's my second cousin
there's something seriously wrong with
you
I'm an Uber driver and I don't have a
car I'm gonna lose my house you think I
chose this
[Music]
look at this need a car date our son
this summer and bring him out of his
shell before College in exchange will
give you a Buick Regal date is in quotes
it's got to be a joke right now have you
seen these helicopter parents I'm
surprised they're not gonna them
themselves
he's just been so worried about our son
he's going to Princeton in the fall no
I've heard of it you know we tried
everything to bring him out of his shell
he doesn't come out of his room he
doesn't talk to girls and drinks so when
you say date him do you mean date him or
date him yes date him date him hard I'll
date his brains out he volunteers at the
animal shelter hi mind if I touch your
wiener what your dog
how about I give you a ride home
um this isn't the way to my house it's a
shortcut
near my hostage
what you got down there something for me
why you tried kidnapping me you're 19.
grow up
kid is unfuckable have a drink together
he'll have a Long Island Iced Tea
[Music]
this is the worst iced tea I've ever had
one thing about me I'm the baddest alive
dance party I don't know what to do I
just know my mom would have wanted me to
save the house he's probably just
nervous
[Music]
get the in here right now okay
I'm just a bit of a romantic he's
actually really sweet the best part
about getting older is not giving a
what people think I'm an adult now I can
make my own decisions that's that's good
you want to save it
[Music]
come on you're getting out of here you
don't belong here touch me get away from
her stay
I can't lose my license